jetzt blicken wir auf einen wichtigen
tag in einem prozess das opfer
erschossen und
zerstückelt auf grausame weise allein
diese worte genügen dass uns ein schauer
über den rücken läuft ja das ist eine
rock am ort ein besonders grausamer
rocker mord und jetzt geht dieser
prozess in seine wohl wichtigste phase
kronzeugen tag in diesen stücken
rockerprozess
hier sitzen die angeklagten auf der bank
einer senkt den kopf ein weiterer
versteckt sich hinter einem blatt papier
zwei weitere machen keine anstalten ihr
gesicht zu verdecken insgesamt sechs
hells angels müssen sich für den mord an
km verantworten doch der mutmaßliche
todesschütze der fehlt
ramin nektar palast er verhöhnt deutsche
fahnder und auch seine opfer auf
instagram für seine 122 tausend follower
postet der 33-jährige preist videos und
fotos in denen er sich in ihrer an stolz
sind freiheit zeigt dann ein ausschnitt
aus dem film forrest gump in dem forst
weg läuft das projekt passt das nennt
sich auf der flucht sein
es folgt ein foto im liegestuhl unter
wasser das ist abtauchen und das ist
noch nicht alles am ende der post rocker
insta story ein video in dem der hells
angels breit könnten mit sonnenbrillen
liegestuhl am kolleg dazu schreibt er
und wie nennt sich das als wolle er
damit sagen ich bin nicht auf der flucht
ich bin nicht abgetaucht ich genieße
mein leben bei der iran eigene
landsleute nicht ausgeliefert weitere
videos auf seinem instagram account
zeigen ihnen mit seinem lamborghini
posen einmal drehte auf dem heißen motor
ein spiegelei wohl um allen zu zeigen
was er für ein toller kerl ist sein
ganzer körper ist tätowiert neben
üblichen hells angels symbolen ziert
auch ein hakenkreuz seinen oberarm
gefahndet wird nach héctor parra ist
wegen des mordes an km im jahr 2014
dessen leichnam zerstückelt im rhein
gefunden wurde bild reporter frank
schneider war vor ort dabei für uns
begibt er sich nochmal auf spurensuche
an die verschiedenen auf in der orte der
leichenteile nach aussagen des
kronzeugen und auch nach ansicht der
ermittler der mordkommission hier in
duisburg von die täter damals genau in
diesem bereich mit ihrem auto und dann
gingen sie mit den leichenteilen dem
torso und einem arm des ermordeten
rockers zu dieser brücke und dann
trieben danach die teile dem
rheinpreußen hafen im wasser der torso
wurde später auch hier gefunden der arm
trieben ihnen rein hinaus und wurde dort
am genfer entdeckt im februar 2014 wurde
hier am rheinufer das erste leichenteile
des ermordeten rocker km gefunden es war
sein arm die polizei wusste sofort auf
grund der tätowierungen es handelt sich
um einen hells angel eine mordkommission
wurde gebildet und die ermittler gaben
sieben jahre lang nicht auf diesen fall
endlich zu klären und haben nun endlich
das ergebnis und wissen was damals hier
passiert ist
von dieser brücke hier wurde der torso
und das trübe wasser des rheinpreußen
hafens geworfen deswegen erinnert bis
heute hier diese trauer stellte an den
ermordeten rock en seine eltern haben es
eingerichtet man sieht mit einem blumen
herz und auch ein kreuz und sie sagen
sie sind endlich froh dass dieser mord
aufgeklärt wird und hoffen jetzt dass
die beiden flüchtigen täter auch noch
gefasst werden
für den flüchtigen mörder rami nektar
parat hat marlies noveski die mutter des
ermordeten km eine klare ansage
[Musik]
august kann
dass er menschen kopf und arm
abgeschnitten hat er sich da
rechtfertigen zu seinen kindern
der kronzeuge führte die ermittler der
duisburger mordkommission zu dieser
brücke hier über den rhein-herne-kanal
er sagt wir haben von dieser brücke
betonklötze ins wasser geworfen darin
sind die leichenteile und auch der kopf
des ermordeten rockers polizeitaucher
rückten dann durchsuchten das wasser des
rhein herne kanals und fanden dann in
augenzeugen beschrieben die betonklötze
daten die leichenteile sie wurden
obduzieren das war ganz klar es sind die
leichenteile und der kopf und bei m&s
war dann auch klar km ist mit einem
schuss in den hinterkopf getötet worden
die brutalität der mutmaßlichen mörder
macht bei den razzien den einsatz von
schwerbewaffneten sek beamten und einem
ram panzer nötig
doch noch kann die akte nicht
geschlossen werden denn zwei männer sind
noch immer auf der flucht einmal pro
charakter passt er soll er die tödlichen
schüsse auf km abgegeben haben denn er
hatte ihn für ein spitze gehalten und
als präsident des hells angels charter
persönlich rache genommen außerdem sein
clubkamerad mustafa hände dieser wird
wegen zweifachen mordversuchs an einem
verfeindeten bandido und seiner freundin
im jahr 2013 gesucht
bei uns im studio ist chefreporter frank
schneider herzlich willkommen andichten
morgen grausame tat wichtiger tag
wichtiger zeuge der kronzeuge wir wissen
wie gefährlich es ist in solchen kreisen
und in solchen fällen auszupacken warum
hat er sich entschieden genau das zu tun
ja wir können nur im endeffekt auf das
hören was er selber sagt und hat bei der
polizei ausgesagt er will sich deshalb
auto und er will deshalb erklären was
wirklich passiert ist aus dem einfachen
grund er hat gesagt er hat es nicht
ertragen zu wissen da ist eine mutter
die ihren sohn nicht beerdigen kann er
hat sich immer vorgestellt hat er gesagt
was wäre es wenn er derjenige gewesen
wäre wenn seine mutter um ihn trauern
würde aber nicht wüsste wo er ist weil
die leichenteile bis auf dem torso und
den arm ja lange nicht gefunden wurden
und da hat er sich irgendwann
entschlossen zu sagen ich kann damit
nicht leben ich kann auch mit diesem
wissen nicht leben mit dieser schuld
nicht leben ich will mich outen denn er
war an dem mord selbst der nicht
beteiligt sondern nur in
anführungsstrichen an der beseitigung
der leiche und deshalb hat er ausgepackt
und hat dann die polizei auch wirklich
zu den fehlenden leichenteilen geführt
eben insbesondere auch zu dem kopf die
in beton gegossen werden wie gefährdet
ist dieser mann der jetzt auspackt ja
ist heute morgen herr vor gericht
erschienen heute ist der wichtige tag
heute packt er vor gericht aus er hat
natürlich schon bei der polizei außerdem
packt auch eine videovernehmung von ihm
gibt es schon aber heute muss er eben
vor gericht aussagen und der ist mit
einem personenschutzkommando gebracht
worden in einer gepanzerten limousine
mit begleitfahrzeugen weil er natürlich
als gefährdet gilt mit ihm steht und
fällt irgendwo der prozess er hat
natürlich auch viele beweise geliefert
hat die beamten ja auch zu den
leichenteilen geführt haben sieht man
dass er die wahrheit erzählen muss uns
wüsste er nicht wo sie gelegen hätten
aber die gefahr besteht natürlich immer
noch dass aus diesen hawker kreisen
möglicherweise racheakte gibt frank das
klingt alles wie ein filmstoff
eigentlich gespielt aber trotzdem mitten
in deutschland ist hier rocker alltag
ein opfer das erschossen zerstückelt
wird anschließend wird mit dieser tat
geprahlt da gibt es quasi influenza
unter den rockern siegt am ende die
justiz oder siegen die rocker nein wir
müssen alle ganz ganz stark hoffen dass
natürlich die justiz liegt aber justiz
siegen heißt ja auch im schlimmsten fall
im zweifel für den angeklagten
deswegen sind die beweise so wichtig
deswegen ist dieser kronzeuge so wichtig
deshalb sind aber auch diese beweise so
wichtig der kronzeuge ja geliefert hat
nicht nur seine aussage sondern eben
auch die leichenteile hat zum beispiel
auch gesagt wo sie das handy des rockers
des ermordeten rockers aus dem auto
geworfen haben an einer autobahn und
dort ist es auch gefunden worden das
sind natürlich alles so viele details
woher soll er sie wissen wenn er nicht
wirklich dabei war und deswegen kann man
wirklich nur hoffen dass dieser prozess
mit verurteilung für diese mutmaßlichen
täter muss man ja noch sagen endet
letzte frage franck muss dieser
kronzeuge ab jetzt mit personenschutz
leben ja das ist immer die frage wie
geht das weiter während des prozesses
sicherlich aber wie es danach weitergeht
muss man sehen bekommt er vielleicht
eine neue legende eine neue personalien
lebt in einer anderen stadt das muss man
sehen der hat auch familie der hat auch
angst das sagte er auch aber hat gesagt
ich mit dieser schuld konnte ich einfach
nicht mehr leben und er ist ja da
reingerutscht das sagt er auch in seiner
aussage er wollte das ja gar nicht sie
haben ihn mehr oder weniger da
reingezogen und plötzlich wurde er
konfrontiert damit der ist tot der
muster stöckelt werden du musst helfen
und du hängst das hat man nicht auch
klar gesagt du hängst du jetzt mit drin
und wenn du redest dann sterben deine
familie und das hat man ihm damals
gesagt aber irgendwann hat er gesagt
weil die schulter schuldgefühl so groß
dass er dieses risiko eingegangen und
man kann nur hoffen dass irgendwo neu
anfangen kann unser bild chefreporter
fangen schneider über den sogenannten
und spektakulären stückl rockerprozess
danke
[Musik]